[Music]
foreign
[Music]
firstly I guess like I want to talk a
little bit about expectations and I was
I was thinking about
um
I was thinking about that with you like
do you do you feel like when you go into
a conversation in real life with
somebody like all the time there's
always some sort of expectation about
how you are who you are well that's a
really great question it's funny because
last night I like was telling I was
sitting at dinner with some friends and
you know it's not like I get people come
up to me all the time like I look like
every other 36 year old squat white
woman in the world so it's like there's
not it's not like I'm being sort of like
picked out of a Crowd by adoring fans
but sometimes people recognize me and
oftentimes those conversations involve
someone sharing something like
incredibly personal that maybe
intersects with something that I've
experienced possibly crying and so it's
like those it's always so interesting to
have those conversations and then just
like return to the conversation that's
happening at the dinner table so someone
came up to me last night and she was
sharing the fact that she had been
hospitalized for mental health issues
she was talking about that at the same
time her girlfriend was like my cousin
went to Camp with you and has a painting
that she did of you in her bunk and I
was like this is a lot to process
this is like really a lot to process and
I was actually thinking about you
because I was thinking about the weight
like everyone has a way that people
react to them and you have a way that
people react to you it's actually like
kind of different than who you you are
and I mean it's either like like a woman
screaming and throwing like undergarment
at you or you're like cut that out yeah
and then or I told you one [ __ ] story
yeah I know it's happened multiple times
or it's like a man being like my dude
like my my dude The Punisher or whatever
and it's like neither of those people is
who you are you're like I mean you have
obviously like you contain multitudes
your house has many mansions to quote
Etna St Vincent Malay but like you are
also like an incredibly like tender
soft-spoken person with a massive
interior life and so it must be
interesting for you to have to like deal
with those expectations and figure out
how you're going to react in a way that
like feels doesn't make you feel like
you're stepping outside yourself all the
time is there something that you feel
like you need to defy the expectation or
do you need to play against it or play
towards it or do you really strive for
just kind of being where you are while
you're there
I think I used to and I love when people
are like you and John Burns all are
close friends and I'm like
you know like I know that it doesn't
make sense if you're comparing our
bodies of work but if you were to
compare our inner lives and that's the
thing that I feel like
you're this show touches on is that like
the thing that connects people isn't
necessarily how they project to the
world it's like how they feel and like
people would be surprised to know that
like you and I actually respond to
certain kinds of interpersonal
situations in the same way we have
shared value system like and that's what
makes a friend and I think when I was
younger especially when girls was on I
used to feel like I either had to prove
to people that I wasn't that character
and that I had like a level of adult
maturity and polish that she didn't
because I think especially when you're a
woman playing someone on TV people
conflate your two identities so
intensely although you know what it's
like to have your identity conflated
with someone or I would feel like I had
to come in and be this like really body
funny like girl who could like handle
the sex stories and didn't get tripped
out and could deal with the boys club
and like and I realized like neither of
those things were me right and it took
some time away from playing that
character and sometimes just away from
Pub public life for me to do the thing
that you're talking about which is just
go into a conversation being the most
present authentic version of myself
that's reacting to someone in a way
that's hopefully empathic and genuine
and also being true to my own needs my
own boundaries my own sense of myself
but that was like a lot of work and it's
something that I have to pay attention
to every single day you know watching
girls and being such a big fan of girls
coming up as like a young man I think to
be able to go into your work with like
real Reckless abandonment and to be able
to get um not to be afraid to be naked
and raw and and look for awkwardness
look for ugliness look for Flaws look
you know that's that's a real model of
of Courage what's a model of a
courageous artist to you and and what do
you think it it it takes to be
courageous in art well it's interesting
because you said what did I expect when
I met you and the reason that I was so
excited to me was because like I had
just always been captivated no matter
what where I saw you I started to have
this feeling where I was like okay
that's the person who like I remember
everything from like Wolf of Wall Street
to sicario to Walking Dead like I would
see you and I'd be like oh that's the
person I'm drawn to because I can
recognize that something really honest
is happening right here and like it
would be like I'd be watching a movie
from 2015 and suddenly it would be like
I was in the 70s because you were just
so like present and there and so but I
was also surprised because I remember
when my friend Evan started working
through I was like tell him he's my
favorite actor and when he was like he's
a really big fan I was like oh what like
the idea that you would be watching it
and connect to what it was about but
then when I met you I wasn't sure what I
would experience and I'd also had lots
of experiences of like actors actor male
actors who were not presenting his
female be having a certain kind of ego
around their work or what they did or
having to kind of like like mask it in
this kind of machismo or that but the
thing is when I met you it was so clear
to me that we were looking for the same
thing which is like that we loved doing
it because we loved things that we could
that both scared us and that we could
disappear into and then when we worked
together I understood even more because
we both have this thing where even if
something scares us that makes us
understand that we need to do it if it
scares Us in the right way and also that
our only goal within that isn't to like
meet a larger expectation or contribute
to some like way we think our body of
work is supposed to look but to just be
there deconstruct it and do the most the
version of it that sort of like reflects
the things that we have experienced in
life that have challenged us that have
pained us and so like in working with
you I understood even more deeply like
the harmony between the way that the way
that we do things and I think that's
always been my thing is like if
something scares me if something gives
me shame I want to run towards it and
explore it and open it up yeah which was
so and that's why I knew that I wanted
to write a part for you and that's why I
knew that it was going to be in a story
that was this sort of
kind of about shame and about human
about the ways that we do things that
run counter to our value system and then
how we kind of like relegate that to
ourselves and so and those were the
questions I was uniquely excited to
explore with you because I knew that we
were approaching them when you were
doing girls and you were you know and
you were just sort of like especially in
the beginning did that like can you talk
a little bit about the was there fear
there yeah I mean I think part of the
way that I sold it to myself was I was
like and I just said that someone
yesterday I was like oh I mean I know
it's on HBO but like how many people see
that like 350 like it'll be like a
little bit more than seeing a YouTube
video that I put out but like not as
many as see anything else like I thought
it was going to be maybe 300 like-minded
women would see the show like the idea
that there would become conversation
about it or then conversation about the
conversation was so out I didn't even
let myself contemplate that right and
also because I think it's important to
make what if you had like what if
somebody said hey you know this could be
this I think I probably would have been
like
I would have been like
that's impossible and I also think if
someone had really shown me what it
would look like
I don't think if someone had had like a
crystal ball and they'd been like this
is what it's going to look like when you
put this work out
I don't know if I would have
been I don't know if I would have known
to be scared because I wouldn't because
if they couldn't have said what this is
what it's going to feel like do you know
what I mean I do I guess because my
question is but I was really terrified
and the part that I was terrified about
wasn't necessarily like oh I'm gonna be
naked on television it wasn't
necessarily like oh people are gonna see
this character who is a reflection of
certain parts of my life that have
scared me it was much more about like I
want to prove that I can that I can do
this I don't want the people on set to
feel like they're betting on the wrong
person it was much more about inter my
fears were much more around
interpersonal expectations and being
able to achieve it artistically and
creatively like I went in every day very
afraid of failure but afraid of failure
on this almost like technical level and
and in the moment right like the driver
was like if I'm asking that person to do
it I got to do it too right I guess my
question is like is courage like do you
do you feel like you know you in order
to like really achieve or to do
something courageous you almost have to
ignore ramification you're almost have
to ignore if you and because when I look
at a firefighter who runs into a burning
building right like that person you
could say like look certain people are
wired towards that it's something I talk
about with artists all the all the time
because again in the interconnectivity
of all this if you're talking to a
special forces Soldier if you're talking
to a pro fighter I mean look walking
into the ring like every time you do it
you're [ __ ] scared like every time
you do but it's the people next to you
it's the people that you trained with
it's the people it's it's for whatever
reason you're doing it it's like right
there in the moment and I've seen
some of the most hardened people in the
world that have like really really you
know
really really uh you know had had Real
Time with like real violence put a
camera on their face and and they
completely will and like it it's not
about equating these things or whatever
it is but courage is courage and I and
and
I I guess like because I I really think
now in art and something I want to get
into a little bit later but like I think
now in art there's so many things that
play that make you consider the
ramifications that make you consider are
you gonna offend this product you're
going to offend this person and can you
truly be courageous if you're thinking
about things that are going to come down
the line that's such a beautifully
phrased question like when you were
talking about like people who run into a
burning building like I remember being
at summer camp when I was like 13 and
every girl was jumping off of this
really really like a I don't know like
100 foot rock into a pond right and I
was like we could die and they were all
like but it's fun and I was like we
could die you guys and like I couldn't
do that I just remember feeling so
ashamed because I left and everyone had
jumped off the Rock and I'd been like no
way like that's just I I can't I can't
let go the way that you guys are and
experience this idea that like but if we
hit the water the right way it'll be fun
because I can't stop thinking about but
if we hit the water the wrong way we'll
be paralyzed and but in my creative life
I'm almost like pathologically unable to
ignore ramifications or in like
expressing myself at times I've been
pathologically unable to ignore
ramifications and so it's interesting
when you say that thing about like
courage is courage but we all feel it in
different ways and something that was
very when you ask like what's a model of
courage to me you know the thing that I
always said when people were like it's
so brave for you to get naked on
television I was like it's not brave to
do something that doesn't scare you and
that never scared me just because it
scares you and you're watching but like
there's other things that really do
scare me that are you know you know the
things that scare me disappointing
people going into a conversation and
hurting someone expressing myself and
putting down a boundary and so and my
father will sometimes be like how are
you like I remember recently he was like
how are you able to like make a movie
like sharp stick and put it out and not
care how people feel or get naked on
television and you literally just can't
tell your friend how you feel and I was
like it's just us that yeah and I guess
for me models of Courage are like when I
see somebody do something that is so
like like I watch a lot of Dateline just
because
it relaxes me and but I constantly will
be watching these people who like
you know experience something shocking
in their life they're they you know an
intruder comes from their home whatever
and they practice these acts of like
wild bravery that come from almost like
you're like where does that come from
inside of you almost nowhere and I was
also thinking about that recently in
relation to my mom because like I was
raised in a house of artists so
expressing yourself was a concept but my
mom was raised in a house of like you
know post-world War II uh Jewish Family
where they were trying desperately to
fit into this idea of like Norman
Rockwell Americana and my mom came out
and was basically like goth yeah and
like couldn't not beat off and to me I'm
like you're unbelievable like you were
just like you just busted out of that
with no fear about telling everyone your
life was going to look different than
what they thought it was going to so in
a way I just kind of followed this path
that was already set out by my family
but I look at my mom or other like
specifically female artists but tons of
I mean I look at you know Gertrude Stein
and Alex B tokless who announced in the
you know just were publicly queer in the
1920s like these people who were able to
express their identities despite every
force that was
oppressing them to me are
unbelievable models of Courage of
Courage
foreign
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's John Bam
Bam the dog uh first on behalf of both
of us and everybody from the real ones
team I just want to sincerely thank you
guys for for tuning in the folks that I
bring on the show they're family to me
and uh being able to tell their stories
and bringing you into their world
something I'm I'm just super proud of
and uh again grateful that you guys tune
in we've decided we want to take things
just a step further we're going to
introduce a patreon community and
basically what that means is if you
become a part of this community look I
already board Bam Bam if you want to
become a part of this community you're
going to be able to hear episodes early
and all that ad free and all that good
stuff but there's all this behind the
scenes footage all this stuff that we've
shot that really brings you into the
folks that we've had on the show really
brings you into their world you're going
to be able to do live chats with me and
the folks that I bring on the show to
talk about their world talk about the
issues that they're dealing with but
their triumphs and their tragedies just
go to patreon slash real ones on this
website that you see right there right
on the screen that's right in front of
you this whole idea was something about
building bridges and and bringing people
together and bringing folks that often
don't get the mic and giving the mic to
them so the fact that you guys tuned in
means the world anyways again thank you
be good to each other out there rock and
roll